allez c'est un jeu de piste géant auquel
se sont prêtés près de 600 enfants
scolarisés à Loches et dans les villages
alentours retour sur la troisième
édition du rallye du patrimoine un
événement organisé pour faire connaître
la cité royale aux enfants du secteur et
aborder de manière ludiques l'histoire
locale Laura Chauvet
une journée de cours hors les murs pour
ses écoliers chaque année le rallye du
patrimoine rassemble les enfants de
loches et ses alentours en véritable
enquêteur ils s'aventure dans les rues
du centre-ville à la recherche d'indices
l'autre moitié du groupe assiste quant à
elle à des ateliers au campement
médiéval grammes d'arbres jeux de
société tir à l'arc il y en a pour tous
les goûts
le projet a été lancé par deux
enseignants en 2018
l'objectif faire découvrir le patrimoine
qui les entoure tout en s'amusant une
année on s'est aperçu qu'autour de notre
patrimoine les enfants de CM1 qui
avaient quatre d'entre eux connaissaient
la cité royale et ça ça nous a vraiment
interrogé et puis donc on a commencé à
monter des activités pour nous deux
classes et quand on s'est vu la masse de
boulot que c'était on s'est dit que
c'était dommage de pas en faire profiter
les autres collègues donc on leur a
proposé voilà si on fait un rallye clé
en main est-ce que ça vous le reste et
là tout le monde a dit oui la première
édition a réuni près
de cette année ils sont plus de
atique parce que c'est marrant avec
d'être avec les copains qui ça aide à
apprendre des choses sur la vie le
patrimoine et les gens qui avaient avant
nous comme activité les dégustations bah
là on est allé manger des plantes
c'était bon
une organisation qui a un prix 45000
euros pour une journée comme celle-ci
civisme histoire langage tous les
ateliers sont adaptés à chaque tranche
d'âge